a US air strike on armed groups linked
to Iran one of dozens across Iraq and
Syria longrange bombers flew directly
from the US to take part in the
operation the White House says the
attack sites were carefully chosen to
avoid civilian
deaths US military forces struck more
than 85 targets at seven facilities
utilized by Iran's Islamic revolutionary
guard Corp and the militant groups that
they sponsor three of facilities are in
Iraq four of them are in
[Music]
Syria Iraq has condemned the strikes as
a violation of its sovereignty Syria
says the US is fueling conflict in the
region both countries have reported
casualties the bombings were framed as a
response to a drone attack on American
forces nearly a week ago three soldiers
were killed and dozens were injured at a
military base in Jordan their bodies
returned to the us on Friday US
President Joe Biden promised a response
and now that's been delivered presumably
the um goal of the campaign is to
reestablish deterrence which is at the
end of the day a political and a
psychological condition so uh the
question is can the these actions
inflict enough damage on Iranian
interests that uh the Iranians will uh
you know basically step back from doing
this sort of thing again in the future
some armed groups in Iraq are now
pledging more attacks on us Targets in
the
region the White House says it's not
seeking broader conflict in the region
but it suggested more strikes are to
come saying what began tonight will not
end
tonight Vincent Mahan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer